こんにちははじめ社長ですというわけでも対ドルにもあると思うんですけども
はじめしたちょーっとチャンネル開設して
外れんがタッチました
ドイツを見てくださったみなさん本当ありがとうございますイーヤー早かったですね
結果8年ってどんなよる長い時間やってんだって話なんですけどあなんかちょっとあの
急になることがありまして
去年とか2年前もちゃんとあの何周年記念ってお祝い動画だしてなんですけども年か
去年とか普通にこれまでなんか
5-30日がその動画ちゃんチャンネル開設日だったんですけどなんか今自分で調べ
たら youtube の8型の31日に変わってて
後ろでとって思ったんですけどなんでなんでしょユーチューバーさん汗てください
チャンネル開設日会が今8月308月3度和泉2-はなんかどっちか分からないという
浮上するあの俺もわかんないんですけどもマーケット new 2部の3年見るとなん
か自分の法人
u 8月の31って書いちゃったんでとりあえず8月だ31日ということにしておき
ましょう
8月最後夏休みが終わりですはいというわけでまあ
そうだね8年間 youtube 行ってきてまあとりあえずよく初年間も続けている
なよしよし
って感じでございます8年も度ごと続くことってなかなかないと思うんですよね
多分 youtube 以外に8年間何が続いていることないで本当になんか自分の中
でも youtube nacs とほど何者こんな
なぐらいすごいいろんなことをやってきたなって思っております
8年か19歳の頃から始めてますからね店で理性での頃から初めて多いはニーズなら
おおっ
本当に何でしょう視聴者さんとかねえ8年間でいろんな方がいらっしゃったし昔から
ずっと応援してくださる方もいれば
最近応援してくださった方もいるし途中ですっげぇ応援してくれただけどと付いたらい
なくなっちゃったと思いましたホンダいろんな人
相手あの皆さんのおかげで私こうやって動画制作をさせて頂いておりますので本当に
みなさんには感謝しております
といえつつも皆さんのために動画を作らなきゃっていう意識しちゃうと
求められるものに合わせて動画作り始めると自分の本当にしたいことができなくなると
思うんで
まあスタンスは変えず自分のやりたいことをやりたい動画を撮るというの
で今後も一貫していきたいとおもいますそうねなんか8年間やってきて
う
[音楽]
自分の下へ自分のしたいことから撮りたいとかもちょっとずつ変わってきたり
まあいろんな変化とか周りのなんとかとかね芸能人の参入がスゲーとか色々あるんです
けども
ポータルしていたいことは本当さの new tube っていうのが大好きだなって
いうのが思っていることでございます
はいみなさん思いましたねお前いつ
重大発表するんだというわけであの重大発表という感じでなんか俺8学すげ忙しいん
ですよかんだしてなかったんですか twitter とかもなんか過ぎ忙しいかんだ
したりちょっと爪爪で実はでねあることをやっておりましてそのあることが何かって
いうのがよりスゲー回りくどいをまとめています
9月1日明日の19時の増加でございます
タイプ
[音楽]
すー
入ってゆけでもの9月1日の15時のために8月結構忙しかった雪あります他にも
いろいろ仕事をしたんですけどもなんで忙しくなったっていう方もそれが一番ですね
先ほどが見て下さったらは勝ったと思ったんですけど
を伺いたい婦さんが作曲してくださっておりますアーマー何するか言ってないですよね
ダイスかといってない何のためにビートルして誰かも言ってないですよね
受けずほんと僕の夏のすべてが詰まってる時もさん今ではありませんチャンネル開設が
8月30か2月31日なんですけども初めて動画を出したのが9月の1日なんで
記念すべき初年目は1本目の動画という事で足下が着いたのは19時あの
んあ俺目指してみてくださいとかまぁ言わないタイプなんですを言わせてください見て
くらはい
お願いしますと行けない今後始めそういう
しくお願いしますじゃあなまず見てに阿蘇19時本当にこんなにおねしょぞ
bl tl パッケージ
[音楽]